- Good morning, Believe Nation.
It's Evan, my one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe
in themselves and my sincere hope is
that if you see in
yourself, what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
To help you on your journey
today's message is "Don't
dwell on the past."
Over to you Joe Rogan.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
♫ I wake up every mornin'
- Your life would feel better and richer
if you had a goal, you chased that goal,
you accomplished some things,
and you would get this
boost of confidence.
You'd get this boost of self esteem.
Whatever it is that you're into doing.
Maybe you're into drawing comic books.
Maybe you're into making
pottery or sculpture.
But find whatever the ff
that is, and pursue that
instead of doing nothing.
The people that are doing nothing,
those are the real...
Look, doing something
might be as simple as like
that Alex Honnold guy.
He just climbs rocks,
but he's world class climber
- [Man] It's somethin' though.
- It's something.
- One of the most common
questions that I get asked
when I do interviews is
Evan, if you could go
back in a time machine
and go talk to your 20 year old self,
what message would you give yourself?
And it's a question I always
have a hard time answering.
I guess it's one of
those standard questions
that people like to ask you
at the end of interviews.
I have a hard time with it.
One, because I'm so grateful
for where I am right now
that I wouldn't really change anything.
Everything that I went through
has lead me to where I am right now,
and I'm happy where I am right now,
and so thank you for
all those experiences,
even though some of them
may have been crappy.
Two, I don't spend time
thinking about what didn't work,
and spend time livin' in the past
and I think to be an entrepreneur,
to be enthusiastic, to be optimistic,
to chase these dreams
that're goin' forward
you can't do it when you're
just stuck in the past
dwelling on all the mistakes
you made and how much you suck
and everything that
went wrong in your life.
I've had a lot of negative
things that have happened to me
but I don't remember them.
I don't focus on them.
One of the hardest exercises
I had when I first started
workin' with a media coach was
coming up with my foundation story
and thinkin' about the hard times I had
in my startup business
when I was making the few
hundred dollars a month.
I didn't even remember those stories.
All the negative things that
happened to me just pfft.
I don't think about them anymore.
I think about what I'm focused on now,
where I'm tryin' to go,
and I get how those stories can help.
They can help tell the journey.
It can help with you
guys who are watching.
Being able to access those things can help
but I don't live there, anywhere close to
on a weekly or monthly or
definitely not a daily basis.
I just don't think about negative things
that happened in the past.
I think you'll see that
consistently with successful people.
And then the third answer then becomes
okay, I need to say something.
I don't want to just tell
them that their question
doesn't really touch me.
The only think I come up with is
I would just tell my younger
self to believe more.
To believe in myself more.
To believe in the mission more.
To believe that I'm going
to do great things more.
To believe that it's
going to work out more.
But I wouldn't go and change
any of those specific things
that a time machine might be able to fix.
But the time machine doesn't exist
so stop focusing on it, right?
If the message is what would
I tell a young person today,
I love that question.
But what would I tell
myself from 20 years ago?
I can't.
I love possibilities.
I love thinkin' about the future
and things that are impossible
and how to fix that,
but this is actually
impossible right now, right?
There's no way to go back and
tell my younger self something
so I don't focus on it.
I don't care about it, I don't
want to go out and do it.
If you gave me the option,
maybe that's a different choice
but just livin' in the hypothetical
and dwelling on the past
is not interesting to me.
Again, if I look at this YouTube channel,
we've had a lot of failed series.
I've had a lot of videos
where I really sucked,
where my message was okay
but my delivery was really terrible.
I don't have a video
that I'm least proud of.
I don't look at that video and say
wow, that video's really terrible
and it haunts me moving forward.
I've had a lot series
that didn't work out.
We recently canceled
the Believe Love series,
which I loved and I found really useful
but you guys didn't,
so I might use that myself personally
but not share it with you.
There's been tons of other series though.
We have a spot in our calendar
that is just for tests,
where we're always testing new series,
whether you guys agree to them or not.
You guys liked them, you
want to share them or not.
We had a series on morning routines.
We had series on favorite
books from entrepreneurs.
We had a series on, I
forget what we called it,
where we compared two
contrasting points of view
and said, hey find the line between them.
And tons of other series
that I don't even remember.
Even thinking about the
series that we canceled,
I don't even care about it.
I can't even access it
because I've just moved on.
I encourage you to do the same.
So many people just live in their past.
Because one thing didn't work out once,
now nothin' is ever
going to work out again.
You don't have to be the
accumulation of your history.
You can set a new path for yourself.
I would just try to spend
as much time as possible
thinkin' about what you're doin' right now
and thinkin' about where you want to go.
Everything that happened, happened.
Try to see the positive of it.
It lead you to where you are right now.
Be grateful for those experiences
that guided you to be the
person you are right now
and this vision that you
have to move foreword.
That's it, move forward.
Spend as much as your
mental energy as possible
living in the present
and where you want to go
and not dwell in the
things that happened to you
'cause you can't change the past.
The question today is, I'm curious.
Is there something from your
past that is haunting you?
An experience, a person,
a limiting belief?
Something that is
haunting you and you feel
is preventing you from moving
forward with your life,
with your business?
Leave it in the comments below.
Release it.
Let it free.
Let it go, so that you can
focus on buildin' something
way more positive.
I want to see that in the comments.
If you leave a comment
within the first couple hours
of this video goin' live,
you might win one of our top
two prizes that come out daily.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Lazar Jovanovic.
Thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book "Your One Word."
It really, really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- Well, the first time that I
really got involved in UFC was
everybody had seen UFC 1.
I saw UFC 1,
but when we got involved in those
because we started taking jiu-jitsu.
Through jiu-jitsu we fell
in love with the sport
and we started to meet
some of the athletes.
When I say "we," I mean me
and the Fertitta brothers.
It was really learning about the sport
and meeting the athletes
that completely got us
literally addicted to the sport.
When we went to our first ever UFC event,
it was down in New Orleans
at the UNO Arena down there
and literally, me, Frank, and Lorenzo
were sitting in the
audience going, "Holy shh.
"Imagine if they did this
and imagine if they did that?
"This thing could be big."
Then, once we bought it,
our goal was and always has been
to make this a global sport.
- Go ahead, tell me what
your vision board looks like.
Can you share some of the
things that're on there?
- I used to have a
traditional vision board
where you would take things that you want
and put 'em up on poster
board, whatever, whatever.
That's cool, I did that
when I did the seeker, but
to me, the best vision
was the one you write down
your long term or short term goals.
Write down everything that
you want to accomplish
and keep those things in your mind
because your mind is what it makes
it manifest in the reality.
Your thoughts really do become things.
I don't have a college
degree or anything like that.
All I have is, back in 1998, I said
I want to be a super jock.
I said I want to be one of the
biggest radio personalities
on the planet.
I said I want to be in that
Wendy Williams, Tom Joyner,
Doug Banks, Howard Stern,
you know, Bill O'Reilly,
Rush Limbaugh, I want
to be in that number.
When they think of Charlamagne,
I want them to think of me like that.
I want to be my generation's that,
because all of those guys,
it's the natural cause that thing,
that power eventually fades or weakens.
All of them, it's just like the NBA,
or music, it was the Magic
Johnson, Larry Bird era.
There was Michael Jordan era.
Now it's Lebron James era.
That's just the way
things are in the game.
I knew that eventually it would be my time
if I wanted that, and so I claimed it.
My vision board is a
really just a notebook
with everything that I want in my life.
- We always had this goal in sports.
I give the credit to my coaches
for instilling that in me.
It's like always creating this goal,
this part of time to achieve something.
During that time nothing else mattered.
It didn't matter what was
happening at school for me.
It didn't happen what was
relationships didn't matter.
It was just like achieving that goal.
And maybe it comes back to
like childhood or something
where I just wanted to be a great athlete.
When I get in that mind frame, I guess
I don't know, I just
want to achieve the goal
more than anything else.
That's what I like to do.